[Music]
getting weird here pistols gonna prevail
for a bit but brokey hits the shot and
can very well bring this bag fast from
brokey another perhaps Elise pinned down
there's the round for phase they stand
on their feet
froakie's activated from long delayed
peek but it works all swapping to the 50
what a shot when they needed it the most
and at that 40-second mark they know
exactly what's coming it is long 5 there
are duels to win and brokey through the
box takes this back down to the to be 2d
spot snap deals with it and only now has
nitro left to handle with bomb it's one
of three positions and broke his fake
plan as a number of times so he's gonna
eventually be worried about long doesn't
see the peak and now he knows that
timing nitro could be close but there
are options so he keeps his head on a
swivel now he started to panic swapping
weapons ending that's it the young gun
Wow this is just plain thing for our
suggested amazing javelin team and that
is the right move beautiful stuff from
brokey calm and collected throw key not
white swinging just yet not quite sure
if he's extended now he gets the
confirmation and the one tap
assassination kill took way too long
about it oh what a great shot from
brokey into a one-on-one he's got a
chance smokes gonna go down he's aren't
an ak-47 always ready to try and clutch
it no AMA here
she waited great round here a brokey
lying in wait they haven't spotted him
yet there's the first outfit as well
he's gonna finish it at the triple kill
well done from brokey looking very
composed there listen this is the
absolute literal baptism of fire like
you get thrown in the deep end if you're
a fan of professional csgo chances are
you've heard of brokey uses smooths or
watch the players you can just fly on
through and show us what we need to see
and what we need to see right now is
brokey making a stand at the peep on the
site and only 19
the young laughing star burst onto the
scene surprising everyone quickly
becoming one of the game's rising stars
pirozhkis activated from long delayed
peak but it works all swapping to the 15
what a shot when they needed it the most
that was ridiculous seriously the young
opera is absolutely killing it on faze
clan blossoming into a lethal threat
during clutch situations simple started
to wake up now but still it's gotta be
up to Bronte to try and bring this one
back in their favor p250 is draw the
perfect weapon to take that Perfector
though ain't no good five boomers is all
I think it gets his kill Chad looking
for the quick scope now and this is
where brokey shines
if you can show us another clutch here
it would be absolutely fantastic two
versus one right now pressure is on time
to work with Srpska boys and this is
also what this this smoke is huge he has
a gap does he know another players close
bro keep laying around Iceland he's got
boom into the world he's done it but
before he was top fragging I'm one of CS
goes best teams broke he was an unknown
player hiding in the shadows of lower
tier CS 3 flash assists and then one
kill from trees broke he closes and
Epsilon take out pistol in typical
counter-strike fashion broke II gotta
start competing in local tournaments and
playing on amateur teams like latias
wolf saw at the start of 2019 broke he
got his first break with epsilon esports
a team filled with players from all over
Europe Epsilon had flashes of glory but
ultimate
we couldn't find much major success and
the org dropped the roster after a few
months and with things looking grim
brokey was given an opportunity of a
lifetime this will be the first run with
the new lineup phase is looking a little
cold right now but let's talk first and
foremost about Brockie because he's a
young player very different approach
than what we're used to seeing from phaz
and picking up superstars what's going
on with him yeah as I said rookies like
really young player like we had been
looking like to add like really young
player to our team because we didn't
have one like for a very long time so
just nice to have like some new refresh
button the team so the fact that they
picked up a relatively unknown oper at
the same time as signing a multi major
winning superstar in cold Zehra yeah it
was kind of strange
then we've got rocky who we only really
know for playing the epsilon now X
epsilon we don't really know that much
about this guy this is gonna be a huge
team tear one day before him listen this
is the absolute literal baptism of fire
in that regard like you get thrown in at
the deep end in a stacked group in the
best-of-three format like there's no
easy games you this guy coming him not
to forget the lineup that he's being
brought into right face a very strong
you know personality-wise team but in
his first tournament with faze broke he
popped off alongside the game's best but
again they're pretty much up just get
the pistols gonna close this one out
take the lead back at their hands for K
for broken currently 18 kills having a
pretty good start think you'd be happy
about with that so far
sure phases new roster might have bombed
out of ESL one New York but broke ease
performance got fans excited for the
future the only good thing about phases
performance here was that this broke II
kid um yeah actually probably was the
best player on the team rookies growth
during his time on faze clan has been
nothing short of phenomenal now playing
alongside counter-strike legends like
Nikko olofmeister and coldzera
could be intimidating for a young player
but not for brokey he's proved that he's
something special he must've broken
fighting mm for openers but the bombs
been dropped it's pandemonium simple
trying to restore this map try to
restore this series but he's gonna get
taken down leaving electronic and be
they want nothing to do with it they
stop in the tunnels of wait
what a beginning to this round what a
weird one Electronics gone aggressive
now trying to find these players and/or
bro keys gonna hold the line and at this
point the only knock against him is that
he hasn't won anything big yet but even
in phase clans losses it's become clear
that this young oper is a rising star I
want to mention bro key I need to
mention brookie because in my book this
was a reference game for him I have
never seen him having so many impactful
rounds
clutch after clutch after clutch hitting
all the shots when they needed to
I think broke he was the main reason why
face actually got to double overtime he
was all over the place he was Keith so
many times still not enough though with
all of my strong break and boom ah
serving as the stand-in broke he has
been thrust into the spotlight and well
let's just say that he's embraced it Oh
bro Cana one versus two with the AWP I
can't even believe complexity are in
this round at all they should have lost
it a while ago nice shot from bro keeper
rushes up there with a Molotov there's
nothing you could do about it bro key
it's actually gonna go way too far
bro key with the chance and he gets the
kill no rush he just gave it away that
just needed to be right on top and they
would have had it bro key didn't enter
faze clan as a star player far from it
but if he keeps performing the way he
has been he sure to become one soon
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages